it is June 1st and that means the start
of pride month so we asked some of our
lgbtq plus colleagues right here at CBS
to reflect on the meaning of Pride what
it means to them here are the stories
that they wanted to share with all of
you
[Music]
three decades ago at the ripe old age of
26 I came barreling out of the closet
and announced to my family my friends
and most importantly to myself that I
was indeed a lesbian those early years
were alternatively exhilarating but also
fraught I was navigating existing and
new relationships amid the backdrop of
the ongoing AIDS epidemic and anti-gay
rhetoric
[Music]
West Hollywood was the first place in my
life where I was fully able to embrace
my authentic self it was the first time
I stopped suppressing myself and allowed
me to be me
in 2020 I remember confiding in someone
I might be making this all up but I
think I'm gay
it felt unreal to say that out loud
it also felt unreal to be going through
this kind of monumental shift my own
second puberty if you will in my late
20s
I was a brand new Norman on my own terms
it was such an eye-opening and freeing
time in my life as I was growing my
small financial planning firm I embraced
my gay pride by being an out business
owner in a small New England City for 14
years most of the community knew that I
was gay but I didn't really take part in
any larger or organized events when I
joined CBS in 2009 well that all changed
I swear The Tick Tock algorithm knew I
was gay before I did those were the
types of videos that immediately popped
up when I opened the app and I began to
recognize that I've always felt the most
comfortable in queer spaces once I put
two and two together I was sort of
shocked because it seemed like all the
building blocks had been there and I
just hadn't taken that step there's no
greater freedom than being able to be
yourself your real self not everyone has
that freedom I'm lucky enough to have
the freedom to live my life how I want
to live it today early in my tenure at
CBS I spoke openly about my partner and
another gay person on staff warned me to
be a little more guarded I didn't want
to alienate viewers did I well that the
kind of advice that I knew was not for
me I immediately found the people at CBS
who were trying to launch the company's
first ever LGBT employee networking
group this was instrumental in creating
the 2011 it gets better video find any
adult who you really feel safe with and
talk to that person the responses I
received from employees at CBS stations
across the country was amazing so many
who were grateful that I chose to be out
and proud I ended up taking all of my
dresses out of my closet one day and
putting them all away so I didn't have
to see them and that felt so liberating
I felt like I was Breaking Free from a
box that I had convinced myself that I
needed to fit into
coming out as often generalized as one
conversation and then you go on with
your life and then everything is so
great it's so much more complex than
that it's a constant learning process
and one where I'm not only learning
about my journey but also my partners
and the journeys of other friends whose
experiences with queerness gender and
safety are different from my own I
didn't want things to change I just
wanted to be me sometimes the people who
start to treat you differently are the
ones who said that they would love and
protect you forever
I became committed to being more active
in the community I was at the 2019 World
Pride March I became a board member of
the lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
Community Center in New York and coming
full circle last year 30 years after I
came out
I participated in the three-day
275-mile cycle for the cause raising
funds and awareness to further our
progress toward ending HIV and AIDS
identifying as clear means learning our
history and recognizing those that
fought and continue to fight for our
right to exist where people are invited
to be exactly who they are wherever they
are in their Journey where I get to show
up as my full self some of those
conversations I had after coming out did
break my heart but once the heart is
broken all it can do is heal and in my
healing process I gained new confidence
strength a community and pride
I get to build my own rules I get to
figure out who I am and own it I get to
love who I want what does pride mean to
me it means honoring who I am who we are
as a community and continuing to work
toward equal rights for all of us
oh Bravo Jill Norman Costanza number one
I can't imagine what it would be like
not to be able to be your true authentic
self right where you had to hide
something so number one I love that they
shared the stories the way they the way
that they did yeah good oh I think it's
a good message for everybody who may be
thinking so why should I not it's not
just at work it's at home exactly you
stuck back in two places but here at CVS
we want to say on the first day of pride
month that we do see you we recognize
you and we are here for you and we also
want to say thank you to you Stacy purse
off and Heather Spinelli Stacy produced
it Heather edited because I say this to
you all the time viewers at home it is
very difficult to do those pieces where
there is no track yeah